pouvez-vous nous dire
comment donc alors c'est dans ces
discussions donc vous dites que vous
vous n'y participez pas
que finalement pas de 635 000 a d'abord
un montant de 300000 au milieu nous
sommes d'accord quel montant de 300000
il y a eu un moment donné une
fléchage de 300000 après le comité le
premier comité
préservation du 13 avril donc vous êtes
pas informé de cela je suis pas formé et
vous n'avez pas participé ensuite à une
discussion quelconque entre ce moment là
c'est à dire le mois d'avril et le
comité de sélection qui affiche un
montant de
355 355
000 donc il y a une remontée
ou Cyril karunagaran envoie la première
demande de subvention et le jour où
j'apprends qu'on va avoir là-dessus vous
êtes parfaitement je dirais sur la même
posture ou explication que la ministre
c'est à dire que vous êtes
concerné par le projet mais vous
finalement vous tenez à distance pour
qu'il n'y ait je dirais pas de souci
non donnez-vous je ne vous permet pas je
vous demande juste je ne vous permet pas
je ne précise rien du tout vous allez
retirer tout de suite ce que vous voulez
dire aucune posture chez moi vous
entendez il y a aucune posture je ne
suis pas un homme politique déclaration
vous retirez tout de suite je n'ai rien
de comparable avec Madame c'est clair
rien de compliqué je ne le retire rien
de la même manière que j'ai fait
observer hier à madame la ministre
sur la question de l'équité et de la
transparence elle est utilisée les mêmes
mots que l'inspection générale de
l'administrations
je suis dans aucune posture monsieur je
vous réponds sincérité et avec honnêteté
transparence et bien arrêté arrêtez de
me lancer à la figure des choses rien à
la figure j'ai le droit de formuler de
reformuler comme j'ai fait tout à
l'heure pour être sûr d'avoir bien
compris donc vous venez de nous donner
des éléments